[Music]
in bad parenting news submitted by
Louisiana's bitch-ass mosquitoes what is
the what is the Eco purpose of a [ __ ]
mosquito like what did they to transmit
diseases make you itch you mean that's
the goal that's the real goal or that's
not a made-up goal like rats take the
population control really shouldn't all
transmit disease I thought rats eat the
little [ __ ] that's real cute that
that's what they're going for my heart
that's a squirrel save it in their
cheeks hantavirus YouTube briefly
suspended a family channel over a 2016
video of a father pranking his kids with
laxatives oh my that's pretty bad bro
well what was the prank before we
castigate him I would like to know the
prank I don't know I like that premise
I like that setup there's so many
different types of family channels
there's like cuz when you think Family
Channel you think like really clean and
like well presented and there's ones
that look the parents are making their
kids [ __ ] themselves I want to know did
he just put laxatives in their food did
he also change the locks on the doors so
they couldn't get into the bathroom did
he did he give him a big key ring with a
bunch of different keys and only one key
could open open to next level do they
put superglue in the shampoo oh that's
good Tuffy's tights you know saying I
want to know the exact parameters of the
frame I think it's bad because I think
even putting a laxative in to let the
coworkers drink is considered poisoning
and or some like the attempted murder or
some chef I would I would like to bleed
attempted comedy yeah but what if you
you have a permission slip like a waiver
right now you wrote for your kid I do
give whatever permission to give me
laxative but then because they're a
minor the parent still has to sign it so
the parents sign their own permission
slip so now it's okay the best thing and
I'm predicting I'm predicting right now
dad because this family probably like
their whole living is based on this yeah
they got the kids to sit down and day we
like this we love doing this like cuz
didn't didn't
yeah the abusive one didn't was that the
six kids or what love this [ __ ] patty or
five yeah Johnny five did that right
where it's like we love it when he does
this is so fun that kid sounded like a
[ __ ] like a gun was to us yeah it was
wild
I enjoyed this so much it is great he
was like a POWs damn that's crazy man do
you have a video yeah so this YouTube
channel it's called CJ so cool
and this dude he's 29 years old from
Nevada she has kids you [ __ ] wanted
to change the algorithm [ __ ] photo of
his family girlfriend they got the
pepto-bismol cotton candy theme going on
that's a big family so back in 2016 he
gave his two youngest kids ice cream
laced with laxatives and ninety minutes
later he filmed them as they were
screaming and crying in pain all it does
hurt though oh it hurts yeah if you've
if you've taken a laxative like as an
adult it's like borderline like you feel
your bowels move and cramp and you've
yeah you feel like cramps and you can
feel everything going and it's like
borderline like it hurts so I'm like
just imagine for a kid for sure it's
gonna hurt I never taken laxatives so
what a laxative does so like in your I
already got diarrhea that's why what I
remember from what a laxative does
anyways like in your like whatever gut
lining or intestinal lining there's
something that it secretes so that
pushes your your [ __ ] bowels out and
so it do that so you could push more
crap out and so what's happening is I
after all the craps out it's still doing
that [ __ ] you know so that's why it
feels like a cramp in a hurts yeah the
intestines are still sorting that juice
is that another sign you guys could look
do D juice like you guys are always
going to do like the duty mucus cuz it's
like it forces whatever you do deep
yuccas when you got the [ __ ] fungus
times I only see it on breeze bubble oh
yeah I'm dogs it what the [ __ ] are we
talking like sometimes a dog's take a
[ __ ] when it comes out there's like this
mucus at the end of that theme that
helps it slide out or something oh
that's that [ __ ] though I've never seen
Oh
[ __ ] though that's that [ __ ] though
alright so let me show you guys this
clip I better hurts those little kids
bears better be at least put some
bouncing music behind it at least
hopefully let's see already failed with
no DIY music he's so Tom Green he's a
jerk needs that bounce he's stupid why
pick on little kids all the babies
what's wrong with your stomach oh that
sucks nation just turn the curse tool
that's goes into the restroom and fill
film the both of them cuz they're damn
dude I did not think it was gonna play
out like that now what sucks it's like
you know when you have that stomachache
after you [ __ ] and it still hurts and it
stays there it's like that so when you
take a laxative after everything is out
you're still like farting don't start no
and your stomach is still hurts like the
whole times like another four hours do
you think that was gonna be like good
entertainment I'm gonna go viral
that's what was thinking like as he's
filming it he's like this is not turning
out the way that I think he put the
emoji on the corner we good
poop emoji there tells you where he
thought it was hilarious that he's like
yo when they see this they're gonna
laugh man get eco you could like go to
jail for that [ __ ] though yeah there was
a an investigation for child
endangerment
but the county's Child Protective
Services they couldn't comment on this
story
I don't know exact match so it's just
one of those things that it happened and
then people found out about it recently
or is it like it happened and then
immediately people were no so mad no
that just recently people got mad about
I see so they also found other pranks
that he's done on his channel this
channel has 5.7 million by the way oh
damn he just pranks his kids all day or
it's just one of the things that he does
I guess it's one of the things he does
he's also filmed after his wife had a
miscarriage he gets a break now put
alcohol in the things oh that could be
good that's a good prank dude he also
did a prank where it was a drowning baby
prank where he was telling his partner
that their child drowned
wow that is terrible I kind of want to
be there during his writing process Oh
what are the ten ideas that he had that
he was i okay out of these ten this is
my best one for sure right it was this
other one where he lit fireworks in the
children's bedroom and then film them
crying and tear and then he laughs well
traumatising yeah he laughed saying
quote they think somebody was shooting
and then like backing up I pictured
these two babies and their little bunk
beds and he's [ __ ] lighting fireworks
and the kids are terrified
Bannister's desperate he's like that
whoa that's [ __ ] up well I mean that
just says a lot about our society
because he has 5.7 million there's a lot
about you are there other videos that he
does which is most popular that's wrong
that's the Firecracker my wife's vagina
baby the oven prank if this was a
cartoon it'll be funny his most popular
one has 19 million views it was filmed
11 months ago and the title is baby car
crush surprising my family with a mega
mansion oh that's a nice one I tortured
them to get all this money but the sad
part is it's a prank we're not living in
here this other prank destroyed my son's
playstation prank 12 Millions oh my god
pencil stuck in my eye prank with the
little boy he's holding a pencil and
there's like fake blood he loves
torturing his kids huh damn it they cut
and cut out his channel he's like I
can't pay for this mansion well they
actually did briefly suspended like I
don't know why but don't worry he's back
up and running
he has Beckham foods what do you do in
your YouTube just let's like get rid of
the kids on the channel right but what
if he got the kids consent what it was
like can I throw a firecracker in a room
no yeah sure the one day one of class
he's the higher writer that's not how
parenting works did it that's a hollow
wall works kids could say well cuz
there's people out there these days you
have to ask them for consent if you
can't even change your diaper and once
they give you the consent you can do
what everyone right what
well his premises are not good he just
needs like a running Demers it's [ __ ]
crazy dude I don't even know how bad it
was until I heard the titles what the
[ __ ] I'm just shocked right now
yeah there's this doctor who's the
founder of you'll need a doctor and all
in this article actually you could ask
anybody off the street no that's a bad
idea not really because 5.7 people think
it's a great idea it could also be all
of this like bar like everyone's I
watched and like I can't believe they
subscribe because you're gonna subscribe
to make sure he knows how much video
that start blowing up I got sweet idea
yep I get more followers I can see
myself as 13 liking this [ __ ] yeah I
mean there's your you just don't have
empathy you think you like dark humor
hats yeah but you don't know what it is
yet and if you like let's say you hate
your little brother and you can't do
anything to them then you're like I want
to watch someone else to [ __ ] with the
room this thing see this is where I also
mentioned this to like our previous
video this is where
things are a little [ __ ] up now you
know I mean so kids will be kids right
but that means adults have to be adults
that's the problem they're exploiting it
for sure yeah and adults are trying to
be kids you know it means so that that
voice of reasoning that's supposed to
happen through maturity and age people
are caring more about connecting to this
like stupid youth rather than being the
voice of reason to help them go he needs
videos David yeah I mean you try posting
every single week but that's true he's
running out of material and then he gets
validation for the crazier [ __ ] that he
does yeah that's exactly what this
doctor here you guys she's the founder
of this anti child abuse organization as
she was saying that this dude he's
harming his children and bullying them
to pull pranks on each other and he is
modeling inappropriate behavior and
encouraging it by laughing at it and so
he's teaching his children that it's
okay to harm each other for a good laugh
which ultimately she needs a degree
decision I migrated kidding me dude it's
pretty common sense
she's very complicated Lee said well we
also very understandable man we [ __ ] a
Rando like said it you'd be like
whatever but what's a Rando what's a
Rando random person I favor like Kevin
the mailman says and I'd be like yeah
that's pretty legit I like that a Rando
yeah it sounds like a derogatory term
for like a group like no like like a
like a epic like Rando people [ __ ]
randos Rambo's and randos yeah hey Rand
knows hate those randos ruining the
world right damn randos and randos yeah
so I don't know they just got her
opinion for this article it's not that
she knows this family at all but just
based off of everything we can see like
you guys said it's pretty I can see
where fireworks in the house would be
pretty cool to look at your body that is
a [ __ ] ak-47 might not be the best
idea
he sucks sorry for you subscribe I yeah
you [ __ ] up man you gotta wait until
your kids are like 20 then it's fine
does he suck for surprising his family
with the mega mansion do you yeah
because he tortured his kids and
and did he take it away after yeah I
think he probably should have yeah
that's the next video yeah no apparently
they thought it was a prank when they
were are we gonna go shot dad yeah baby
it's a year prank so at the end of the
at the end of the year lease he's like
it was a prank we gotta get the [ __ ] out
I'm just waiting for the the dear
YouTube video oh I know yeah dear
YouTube I just watched
I love deer you suck when they're gonna
quit YouTube I'm sorry
you know this name I'm waiting for it I
want to see it now and the kids all have
to be like we love our dad is the best
yeah we love it we are saying this of
our own volition oh what the [ __ ] is
YouTube becoming same as it ever was my
friend it's not it is I never saw this
[ __ ] no no it's just the same thing that
it's always been we're like I've said
before when you see one of these
thumbnails you click it like it's it's
human it's like we you see the fire well
you see the house is full of water it's
like we filled our [ __ ] house with
water video or whatever like people want
to click on that [ __ ] because it's like
what the [ __ ] that's interesting yeah
Seema's thumbnails same as everything
that's just the evolved version of like
my cat playing the piano yeah dude take
the same I was in a company that
literally got built on titty thumbnails
I still liked cats playing piano
[Music]
[Music]